there's no job the whole monster will
drive the small businesses lately
voracious giant corporations that lowers
standards
would you come to Walmart for today
I've come to buy cascade dishwashing
detergent did you try the Cascade
complete by the way I it's a little more
expensive but it's very good okay it
will sneak in and destroy our cities
remember the story of the Trojan horse
they said let's bring it in the gates
well that was the last thing they ever
did Walmart is that Trojan horse
it'll strip us of our most basic
freedoms because there's no more slaves
it will turn our children into petty
thieves and also you're putting kids in
jeopardy of getting a record from
shoplifting in this Walmart store the
proclick for the first time some kids
will have a record they will start a
record because kids are kids and they
will go in those stores and pick up
things and securities don't grab them
and that's crime the nation's biggest
retailer is planning its first stores in
Washington DC and New York an opponents
say their cities are under siege we
allow Walmart are coming to East New
York and take care take over East New
York
they'll soon go to the Bronx go to
Manhattan and then they'll be all over
the place so what we have to do
what's getting Walmart opponents so
riled up cheap groceries let's say you
spend $100 a week at the supermarket on
these kinds of items if you bought these
kinds of groceries at Walmart you could
save on average over $700 a year Walmart
is the largest grocery seller in the
u.s. offering prices on average about
20% cheaper than the competition that
translates into tremendous savings for
shoppers but it's not so great for
unionized workers and other grocery
stores they drove down prices everywhere
and the process of driving down prices
they have limited the expansion of
grocery chains who are the only area of
retailing that are actually even
reasonably unionized these days 22% of
all grocery store workers in the US are
members of a union while just 5 percent
of the retail sector overall is
unionized so the one area of opportunity
for unions in retail is being shut down
by Walmart and that's what really drives
them crazy
the majority of anti Walmart activists
in both DC and New York are unionized
grocery workers or people working for
the United Food and Commercial Workers
International which represents unionized
grocery workers in New York City Council
Speaker Christine Quinn and other
powerful members of the council have
promised to keep Walmart out and they
have a powerful weapon
New York's Byzantine zoning code which
makes it impossible to build big without
special permission from the City Council
it's the kind of thing that makes City
Council members relevant when they are
otherwise disproportionate power in the
politics of New York City because of
their disproportionate influence in the
Democratic Party and in Democratic
primaries in New York candidates with
the support of unions almost always win
in the Democratic primary in an
overwhelmingly Democratic City that
usually translates into a win in the
general election so you have council
members who are more willing
do the bidding of unions than they are
of voters in general because they know
that even if voters are upset with them
they're not going to be upset enough to
come out and vote them out of office
because they kept warmer than you say in
Washington DC respect has been harder to
come by for the grocery workers Union
last year Walmart gave two million
dollars to community groups in DC which
helped win the support of the City
Council and the company will likely move
forward with plans to open for stores in
the District anti-walmart activists say
that what they're really after is
well-paying jobs if we're gonna settle
just because the fact that some company
want to come in and take over our
community we do not have to settle no
job is no job when there's no job from
Walmart but full-time employees at
Walmart actually aren't close to what
the average grocery store worker makes
and these jobs are in high demand
Walmart gets about 10 applicants for
each job opening for every two jobs
Walmart has created in other parts of
the country three jobs have been lost in
those very same neighbors it's the
problem of what the French economist bus
they are called the scene versus the
unseen
is that people like the New York City
Council they're so superficial in their
understanding of the American economy
that they can't conceive of how by
saving people money they're actually
going to free up more money in the New
York economy that would create jobs
somewhere else I've done quite a bit of
research in Walmart and the more I look
at Walmart is scary Gary chaw is the
owner of yes organic market a grocery
chain in Washington DC people make the
decision of welcoming Walmart they are
not thinking about the existing business
that they've been participating or
patronized for 30 20 30 40 years Chum
met with members of the City Council to
ask for their help in keeping Walmart
out of the district but there's another
way of responding to competition 11
years ago when Whole Foods came to town
and yes organic business initially fell
off 60% what
you do to bring business back how what
we have to do keep the store clean and
treat every customer as their the only
customer there is and try to buy as best
price that we can possibly get and pass
on their savings and we survive why
wouldn't that happen with Walmart and
Walmart I think it's different there
everything that they sell is already out
there they are taking business from your
existing business but a 2008 study found
that states that have more Walmart's
actually have more small retailers
businesses that fail when Walmart comes
to town are quickly replaced by new
stores that do a better job of appealing
to customers you have another thing well
grocery stores fight a fair battle for
the business of customers or will labor
unions and politicians get to decide
where American shop we fought this
battle before and every other time New
York City has won and I am very
confident that this time around and the
next time around and the time around
after that if it comes to that we will
be victorious again thank you very much